il paraît qu'il ya autour de cette table
une championne de danse moi alors je ne
le savait pas hier à je le savais pas
lire
you'll be mais aujourd'hui je le sais
aix est championne de danse stéphanie
fanny parer aux effets de la danse sont
montrés longtemps
ouais c'est vrai par exemple dans ce
prêt j'ai alors dans tpm paix qui est
une émission médias adorent culture
je propose tout de suite pour se
familiariser avec toute l'équipe que
fanny danse avec tout le monde
fanny est ce que vous êtes prêts à
danser ça vous fait plaisir ah oui on
mettra une danse différente pour chaque
personne
voilà autour de la table c'est donc avec
fanny c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
et vous allez mettre des danses des
notes chez vous qui a le mieux danser
avec fanny on va démarrer dans
sexuellement mature avec toulouse on va
démarrer avec le plus grand danseur de
rungis avance avec des novergie avec
décombres ils dansent avec des sols avec
des mulets avec di merda é lé j'avais
contracture au mollet pas
[Applaudissements]
combien a eu raymond et sa basant sur le
couesnon attention on va on cherche on
va mettre un autre titre indépendant
suel on va demander à celui qui est le
roi de la danse je vous le dis
aujourd'hui pour moi c'est un des
meilleurs danseurs de sa rue n'en fais
sort de sodima b en fait ne séduit et il
habite seule cgil
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il fait peur bien fait pas alors il ya
beaucoup de réactions sur le twitter
jeudi disant est ce gilas une souris
dans le slip la pavane leur accès aux
familles ça va pas mal non maison
comment ils n'ont franchement ça reste
débrouillant pour l'instant pour vous
c'est qui le meilleur danseur entre les
deux entre les doigts fins et quand il a
mal au dos
oui mais même quand il a mal au dos ou
quoi il a des cours de danse avec moi je
pense aussi à sa bonté gilles attention
aux vêtements c'est le don c'est tout ce
serait le troisième danseurs nobel
dansera tout seul après poisson quand
vous serez producteur de l'émission là
on va appeler une personne qui va avoir
des problèmes
cette personne elle est là oh non non
non non je sais que votre femme vous
regarde c'est possible je vais
t'expliquer un truc en plus ce que je
veux dire aux téléspectateurs
la prochaine fois que tu sors pendant
les pubs pour appeler sa femme comme un
canard parce qu'il appelle à toutes les
pulsions canard ce canard wc la jugeant
non mais si on avait déjà vu un canard
mais c'est pareil je t'explique il n'ya
plus d'appels pendant les pubs très bien
pendant les pubs qui restent avec moi
allez faire quoi mettre en prison
hall aux assauts lancés en correction
chez l'insolence et graff chercher je
vais te dire c'est que j'aime beaucoup
oui j'ai qu'un truc à faire j'appuie ici
et on n'entend plus parler de toi et va
danser
[Applaudissements]
raga
alors
ouais bon
c'est un appel je crois non mais ça
aurait été fou quoi danse correctement
je devrais directement du doigt comme
signe d'une enseigne lorsque intitule
ans elle a dit en boîte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on dirait ton père l'avait c'est vrai
vous le trouvez sensuelle dans ce billet
sont bien avant pas du tout bien pas du
tout on va appeler maintenant une fille
une femme une magnifique femme un
ancêtre est las vegas est la plus de 17
kilos d'or sur elle la police m'a pour
isabelle bond
c'est complet
[Applaudissements]
total tient des spasmes tu te calmes
ouais d'accord
qu'est ce que tu vas me faire alors on
est on n'a pas encore fini noël
oh
[Applaudissements]
là dedans mais à mon but on dirait une
fraise tagada et il sait j'adore ce
petit manteau ça très beau chéri bravo
ça te va très bien et le rouge comme a
magnifiquement bien isabelle qui pour
moi était la meilleure pour l'instant
pour moi pour moi je dis pompe pour moi
alors sachez que dans les votes pour
l'instant bizarrement je ne sais pas si
vous avez ces huit en crypté puisque
c'est raymond qui est en tête pour la
fin c'est vraiment qu'ils sont des potes
c'est lui qui est le meilleur danseur et
moi est ce que tu te sens mais
maintenant je danse j'ai un balai dans
le cul donc bah c'est pas là tu parles
aussi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
on leur coupe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quant à m la soirée du bureau des élèves
il avait vu sur kde est resté jeune la
merci clément garder syrie on va rentrer
dans le jeu dans le big three dans le
bic cristal est vraiment pour voir ce
qu'ils sont les trois meilleurs danseurs
a priori de tpm pays alors en fait
aujourd'hui où faire passer je suis
désolé j'aurais dû vous faire passer
avec d'accord masque on le sait tout de
suite dans un instant je vais l'appeler
jean michel maire
il va arriver à faire ça bouge comme a
eu tout comme ça ça va être une
catastrophe
alors je veux bien entendu une énorme
connerie jean-mi danse bien c'est vrai
c'est comme si vous disiez un végétarien
manche de la côte de boeuf non mais
voilà merci gens me disaient d'accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais c'est pas nous sortait the sun il
m'a fait un jeu qu'on appelle à un des
défis j'ai ri la japonaise à une
crispation du doigt les biens anciens
vous la sortez pas mal comme avoir un
mâle du souverain comme quoi on peut
même dans ces camps oignons non mais ça
y est ce assez
c'est l'histoire pour tous les gens qui
nous regardent
on peut même dans sa maintenance avec
une classe d'âge une heure on dit merci
oui je vous ai vu à les tanks et 20 c
toi plaisir jeu rapide tout mettre en
scène
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
total d'anciens bah oui on s'est alors
dit me chatouille il est choqué c'est
mais bon les choses à moi et au canada
allez ce soir va t'asseoir tact et est
en train jason fanni peut être votre
style et bien aimé je crois moi madame a
été choqué un peu pourquoi mais je suis
pas juge mais je m'y attendais pas je
vais te dire si bien c'est pas parce que
moi je les abricots qu'on n'aime pas la
balle à l'inversé
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon là maintenant on va avait
demandé à kelly à la savate et 10 parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens sur les
réseaux qui disent on a hâte de voir
qu'est dit tony danse et ça m'a
tellement à lhassa attention la musique
soul et c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
ok ok
et 1
[Applaudissements]
j'ai des personnes sur les réseaux
sociaux qui me disait ce qu'on peut
faire tout le titre est ce qu'on peut
mettre tout l'album diana cas - oui
c'est parce que vous en voulez encore
plus en plus sensuelle met un truc voilà
c'est ça c'est pas bon là à l'ailé pas
essentielle si mais l'appui on peut
faire mieux alesi ils sont en train de
chercher
[Musique]
à
qu'est-ce ex-travail bordel quand même
quoi donc le dit alors l'animal le don
se comprennent times aussi